Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Dans les années 70,
j’ai grandi à Pondichéry.
Il y avait une grande sécheresse.
À cause de ça, je me rappelle toujours
que, tous les matins, mes frères et moi,
on se levait à 5 heures du matin
pour remplir deux seaux d’eau
qu’on utilisait le reste de la journée
pour cuisiner et se laver.
J’ai donc appris très tôt l’importance
de pratiquer la sobriété.
Mais j'ai aussi appris que sobriété
et générosité sont compatibles.
Car je voyais des gens
très pauvres autour de moi
partager le peu qu’ils avaient
avec les autres.
J’ai aussi noté que les gens
qui avaient des ressources limitées
faisaient preuve
d’une ingéniosité illimitée.
Comme ces gamins dans un village
qui jouent au cricket,
le sport favori des Indiens,
avec un vieux pneu en guise de piquet.
En tant que chercheur,
j’ai passé 25 ans de ma vie
à étudier des centaines d’innovateurs
dans les pays du Sud
qui, comme des alchimistes, transforment
des contraintes en opportunités
et développent des solutions ingénieuses
pour les grands problèmes de société.
Prenez Mansukh Prajapati,
un potier de formation,
qui a créé un réfrigérateur entièrement en
argile qui fonctionne sans électricité.
En Occident, on garde les bébés prématurés
dans des incubateurs
qui coûtent 20 000$
et qui nécessitent de l’électricité.
C’est une solution onéreuse
et pas adaptée aux pays du Sud
avec très peu d’électricité.
C’est pourquoi cinq entrepreneurs diplômés
de Stanford ont créé Embrace,
une couveuse portable
qui fonctionne sans électricité.
Facile à utiliser, elle permet le contact
physique entre la mère et l’enfant
et ne coûte que 200$, soit 1% du coût
des incubateurs vendus en Occident.
Cette solution ingénieuse a déjà sauvé la
vie de 450 000 bébés à travers le monde,
y compris en Ukraine,
où les naissances prématurées
ont triplé depuis le début de la guerre.
Je viens de présenter deux solutions
ingénieuses qui sont low tech,
mais on peut aussi innover
ingénieusement dans du high tech.
La start-up indienne Algosurg utilise
des algorithmes
d’intelligence artificielle
pour convertir
automatiquement et rapidement
des images 2D à rayons X en modèles 3D,
permettant ainsi aux hôpitaux
de faire des diagnostics plus précis
sans investir dans les scanners
ou IRM coûteux et onéreux.
La NASA a envoyé une sonde pour orbiter
autour de Mars qui s’appelle Maven.
Ils ont dépensé 671 millionsde dollars
pour accomplir
cette prouesse scientifique.
L’Agence spatiale indienne a aussi lancé
sa propre sonde Mangalyaan
pour Orbiter autour de Mars, mais elle a
dépensé dix fois moins que la NASA.
Pour réduire les coûts, ses ingénieurs
ont développé une sonde plus légère
et ont fait des simulations numériques
au lieu d’investir dans des maquettes
physiques coûteuses.
Mes co-auteurs et moi avons étudié des
centaines de ces solutions ingénieuses,
allant du low tech au high Tech,
déployées à petite ou à grande échelle.
Nous avons cherché à en déduire
une nouvelle méthode d’innovation.
Hélas, nous n'avons pas pu trouver la
méthode pour innover ingénieusement.
Par contre, nous avons observé que
tous ces innovateurs ingénieux
utilisaient un état d’esprit, un mindset,
qui était tout à fait original.
Nous avons désigné ce mindset Jugaad.
Jugaad et un mot hindi
qui veut dire la capacité ingénieuse
à improviser une solution efficace
dans des conditions adverses
avec peu de moyens.
Cet esprit Jugaad s’incarne
et s’exprime à travers trois qualités :
l’agilité, la frugalité et l’inclusion.
À travers des exemples inspirants,
je vais montrer comment vous
pouvez cultiver cet esprit Jugaad
pour devenir plus agile,
frugal et inclusif.
Commençons par l’agilité.
Être agile, c’est, tel un alchimiste,
savoir transformer
l’adversité en opportunité.
En 2016, à cause d'une terrible sécheresse
dans le sud de la France,
Christian Davico, un agriculteur,
a perdu un quart de sa production.
Sans désespérer, Christian
et sa fille Julie ont lancé Ombria,
une start-up qui développe des
ombrières photovoltaïques intelligentes
qui permettent aux agriculteurs de
se protéger contre les aléas climatiques
tout en augmentant le rendement.
Être agile, c’est aussi sortir
des sentiers battus et innover autrement
en se posant la question
« Pourquoi pas ? »
En 2020, en pleine crise covid en Italie,
le docteur Renato Favero et le designer
Cristian Fracassi se sont demandé :
« Pourquoi pas imprimer en 3D un composant
qui permettrait de transformer
les masques de plongée Décathlon
en respirateurs
pour les patients Covid ? »
Le résultat est une solution ingénieuse
qui a sauvé la vie à des milliers
de patients Covid à travers le monde.
Et si on appliquait cet esprit Jugaad
pour repenser la crise climatique
en une opportunité climatique ?
Au lieu de chercher juste
à se débarrasser du carbone,
on pourrait ingénieusement
valoriser le carbone.
En stockant le carbone, on peut l’utiliser
comme une ressource stratégique,
fabriquer des produits
de grande utilité pour la société.
C’est ce que fait Interface,
leader mondial des revêtements de sol,
qui incite ses clients à aimer le carbone
en leur offrant des dalles de moquettes
à empreinte carbone négative.
Ce sont des produits qui sont fabriqués
avec des matériaux biosourcés et recyclés
qui emmagasinent plus de carbone qu’ils
en émettent durant le cycle de production.
Ici en France, la start-up Carbonworks
a développé un bioréacteur industriel
qui contient des micro-algues
qui se nourrissent
du CO2 capté directement des usines.
En assimilant le carbone,
ces micro-algues forment une biomasse
dont on peut extraire
des molécules à forte valeur ajoutée
pour la nutrition animale et humaine.
La deuxième qualité de Jugaad,
c’est la frugalité.
La sobriété vise à faire moins avec moins.
Être frugal consiste
à faire mieux avec moins.
En Amazonie, les tribus d’Indiens
abattaient un palmier qui s’appelle
le murumuru pour en revendre le bois.
Or, les grains du murumuru ont
sept fois plus de valeur que son bois
car on peut en extraire
un beurre ultra-hydratant
qui peut réparer les cheveux abîmés.
C’est pourquoi Natura,
une marque de cosmétique brésilienne,
s’est associée avec les Indiens d’Amazonie
pour extraire durablement
ce beurre de murumuru,
pour fabriquer des produits
pour les soins capillaires.
C’est une solution frugale
qui est rentable pour tous
et qui non seulement préserve, mais aussi
régénère la biodiversité en Amazonie.
Être frugal, c’est aussi
simplifier au maximum
vos produits, vos services
et votre chaîne logistique
afin d’offrir plus de valeur
à vos clients à moindre coût.
C’est ce que fait Métacar,
une startup lyonnaise
qui cherche à simplifier l’accès
à la mobilité propre en zone péri-urbaine.
Sa solution d’autopartage durable s’appuie
sur des mini voitures électriques
qui s’emboîtent comme des caddies
et peuvent être chargées rapidement
et facilement redéployées
par grappe de dix en station.
La troisième qualité
du Jugaad est l’inclusion.
Aujourd'hui, on est confronté à la double
urgence sociale et écologique.
Donc il faut appliquer l’esprit Jugaad
pour intégrer l’inclusion sociale
et le développement durable.
C’est ce que font Katya, Alix et Louise,
trois ingénieurs agro-alimentaires
qui ont fondé Handi Gaspi, qui emploie
des personnes en situation handicap
pour valoriser les invendus alimentaires.
Handi Gaspi lutte à la fois
contre l’exclusion sociale
et le gaspillage alimentaire.
Être inclusif, c’est aussi redynamiser
l’économie et la vie sociale
dans les territoires,
particulièrement en milieu rural.
En France, un village sur deux
n'a plus de commerces.
C’est pour ça que Virginie Hils
a fondé Comptoir de campagne
qui installe des magasins multi-services
au sein des villages.
Ce sont des lieux conviviaux qui offrent
des meilleurs produits et services
en circuit court.
Enfin, être inclusif,
c’est aussi ancrer l’industrie et son
approvisionnement au cœur des territoires
et valoriser les ressources
au plus près des marchés.
C’est ce que fait Afyren,
une start-up de la bio-économie,
qui est née à Clermont-Ferrand.
Son usine, Afyren Neoxy, en Moselle,
valorise, en recyclant
des résidus agricoles,
en biomolécules de grande valeur
pour diverses applications
allant de la nutrition animale et humaine
aux cosmétiques et lubrifiants.
Mais le plus fascinant, c’est que
ses fournisseurs sont tous situés
dans un rayon de 250 kilomètres
autour de son usine.
Pour résumer,
alors que le monde devient
de plus en plus complexe,
en cultivant l’esprit Jugaad,
vous pouvez agilement transformer
l’adversité en opportunité,
frugalement, faire mieux avec moins,
et inclusivement, régénérer les individus,
les territoires et la planète.
L’esprit Jugaad est vital
pour construire un monde meilleur.
On estime que pour atteindre
les 17 objectifs de développement durable,
il faut investir un total
de 176 000 milliards de dollars
à travers le monde d'ici 2030.
Or il manque aujourd’hui 135 000
milliards de dollars en investissements.
Mobiliser autant d'argent rapidement,
c'est mission impossible.
À la place,
mobilisons nos ressources internes
qui sont abondantes
comme l’ingéniosité,
la résilience et l’empathie.
Appliquons notre esprit Jugaad
pour co-construire un monde équitable,
sain et durable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)